sie hier ist noch keine weihnachtspause
nach haben wir gar kein zeitgefühl
männer ist ja noch gleich weihnachten
aber wenn man verliert aber
wahrscheinlich sind das zeitgefühl weil
es gibt ja nichts zu arbeiten so richtig
ja es gibt nichts zu arbeiten ständig
muss man in kantinen und restaurants und
will die pläne machen was manche leiche
eines tages tun könnte ja wie können wir
uns noch die zeit vertreiben
ja ich habe jetzt so zehn minuten bis
sie zehn minuten bis ich dort drüber
kommen ich muss mindestens fünf minuten
glauben das heißt wir hätten doch ich
habe noch ein mittel also in reichen die
spinner von der art die schuld ist auch
gar nicht groß zu tun werden sie
wirklich gut ich habe mir nichts seine
stars dann auch noch um die zeit
totzuschlagen ich sehe was was du nicht
siehst ja ich sehe was was du jetzt das
ganz kniffliges ich sehe was was du
nicht siehst und das sind gestresste
abgeordneten
das belege brandt von der cdu sein der
wirkte stresst richtig der war es der
kollege brand ist der einzige schwester
abgeordnete heute in ganz entspannt aus
politischer probleme
also wir könnten zum beispiel hier in
mit mehrheit beschließen dass nur die
löhne für die leute die im krankenpflege
bereich tätig sind deutlich erhöhen
aber warum interessieren sich so wenig
abgeordnete für die pflegeeinrichtung
also hier genießt man ja auch alle
vorteile einer betreuten
tageseinrichtung die 200 essen steht ist
diese gilt warmes essen ja der einzelne
abgeordnete ist sich vielleicht auch gar
nicht bewusst dass es ihm selber
passieren konnte also doch mit drin
liegt jung und tag
ich habe eine ganz kurze bitte sie haben
ja die zeit meine nichte kommt heute
hier vorbei in den bundestag könnten sie
kurzen weihnachten für die spieler haben
doch die zeit jetzt das ist doch nichts
zu tun einfach dran ziehen javascript
für geschenke von ihm ein bisschen
improvisieren ja geschenke in form dass
ich meine sie sollte mich unterstützen
weil er einer abgabe für co2 falls es
für den klimaschutz das wichtigste ist
die das überzeugt die sechs jahre alten
schläger zu greifen
wie war's denn gerade war war spannend
oder es sei extrem spannend ich habe so
ein kleines kärtchen so ein schlitz
gesteckt nein
und dann das kärtchen werde das ist uns
ganz wichtig heute geburtstag
spannender kann es nicht mehr werden
also ich mag völlig verblüfft dass der
weg war nichts auch nicht wieder
ja wahnsinn und mit dieser spannenden
geschichte gebe ich zurück nach können
das wird nicht mehr besser leute wir
müssen hier aufhören